افاده مباراه الجزيره في افغانستان نقل
على المسؤولين الحكوميين بمقتله ثمانيه
اشخاص واصابه 19 في تفجير بعبوه ناسفه
لسدف حافله ركاب وسط مدينه مزار شريف شمال
البلاد
في معبر حرتان الرئيسي مع اوزباكستان
واضاف ان تحقيقا بدا حول ملابسات الحادث
وان شخص اعتقل بتهمه طورطه في التفجير ولم
تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليه حتى الان
معنا كابول مراسل الجزيره حمد الله محمد
الحمد الله التفاصيل والدلاله هذا التسجيل
في مزار شريف بالذات
السياحيه في مدينه مزار شريفه ان عدد
القتلى وصل الى 16 قتيلا والجرحى اكثر من
40 جريحا حسب مصادر المسيحيه في مدينه
مزار شريف
والمستهدف هم موظفي دائره الجمارك في معبر
الحيرتان الرئيسي الذي يربط افغانستان
الولايه افغانيه
التي الان يعتبر رئيسي الى افغانستان من
ناحيه الوقود والغذاء ومواد اساسيه
الحكومه الافغانيه تتجه الى اسيا الوسطى
بدل اعتمادها على ايران وباكستان وحتى
الان ايضا لم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن
هذا الحادث وهذا هو يعتبر ان رابع
تفجيرتها خلال 10 ايام حيث كان الاول في
مدينه سمندان المجاوره لمدينه شريف
والثاني والثالث كان هنا في العصر
الافغانيه كامله يوم الجمعه الماضي وهناك
الان وهذا راضي اه هناك ايضا اني اضافه
الى الوضع المعيشي صعب هنا في في
افغانستان بمنع عقوبات امريكيه على شعب
الافغاني وايضا التي تطهر الولد الامني
هناك قلب في الاشاره الى افغاني مناوي جهه
تقف وراء هذه الهجمات هناك يتم تنفيذ
هجمات انتحاريه وتفجيرات ولكن لا توجد اي
جهات تعلن لمسؤولياتها وايضا الحكومه
الافغانيه حتى الان اني لم تحمل فهذا
مصدر قال لشعب الافغاني وايضا هناك مصادر
امنيه تقول بان التحقيقات مستمره حول
ملابسات الحادث وحملت ايضا تفتيش بدات في
محيطه مكان التفجير حتى انه كان عباره عن
وقوه ناسفه وجعت على جانب الطريق لما
تحركت هذه الحافله فتم تفجيرها عن بعد
وهناك شخص اعتقل بتهمه طورته في هذا
التفجير وحتى الان ما زال هناك القوات
الافغانيه موجوده في عين المكان
شكرا لك يا احمد الله محمد شاه وراسيل
الجزيره من كابور